momento de hablar de economía en france
24 y por ello le doy la bienvenida a
daniela blandón daniela empezamos en
perú que autorizó a los trabajadores a
retirar los fondos de desempleo andrés
buenas noches mire el gobierno sancionó
una ley que permite el retiro de hasta
el 100 por ciento de la compensación por
tiempo de servicios también es conocida
en otros países como cesantías este es
un depósito que hacen los empleadores
dos veces al año en mayo y en noviembre
cada uno equivalente a medio sueldo para
que los trabajadores pues dispongan de
ese dinero cuando se queden sin empleo
ahora pueden hacer este retiro
independientemente de que conserven sus
puestos o no podrán hacerlo por una
única vez hasta el próximo 31 de
diciembre la otra cara de la moneda es
que muy pocos tienen ese beneficio ya
que hasta ocho de cada diez trabajadores
en perú son informales otra ley parecida
pero que está pendiente de aprobación
del ejecutivo es la de un retiro
anticipado de pensiones el legislativo
aprobó hace casi un mes del retiro de
hasta 4.800 dólares de los ahorros para
jubilación pero el gobierno todavía lo
está
daniela y el tema pensional también se
movió en otros países de américa del sur
que pasó en chile por ejemplo bueno en
chile tiene que ver con el anticipo de
las pensiones el trámite legislativo ya
está listo para un tercer retiro del 10%
de los fondos pero todavía le falta la
firma presidencial que es lo más difícil
sebastián piñera acudió a un tribunal
constitucional para frenar esta medida
el ejecutivo e nunca ha estado de
acuerdo con el retiro masivo pues alerta
que los ciudadanos se van a quedar sin
ahorros el año pasado se aprobó un
primer retiro del que nueve de cada diez
afiliados se benefició esta vez el
mandatario aprobó la ley pero a
regañadientes el segundo retiro fue
aprobado en diciembre y la coalición
oficialista impuso su proyecto sobre el
que había presentado la oposición aunque
ambos eran casi iguales antes y cuál fue
la noticia en ecuador' respecto a este
tema del viernes de pensiones en francés
entre 4 andrés pues mire a falta de
apenas un mes para que concluya su
mandato el gobierno del presidente
lenin moreno presentó un diagnóstico que
dice que el sistema de pensiones es
insostenible
el informe contó con el auspicio del
banco mundial y un equipo de expertos
concluye que la reforma es impostergable
porque cada vez hay menos cotizantes y
la expectativa de vida de los jubilados
está en aumento también dice que el
sistema actual de subsidio a las
pensiones es inequitativo hay una
combinación de varios factores entre
ellos bajos aportes y un alto nivel de
pensión máxima donde pasamos a australia
porque allí encontraron la solución para
aprovechar las lentejas sin perfectas
usted nos va a explicar que de qué se
trata esto si andrés mire para que las
lentejas de australia se puedan exportar
y de todo el mundo en general deben ser
de primera calidad no pueden estar
agrietadas ni astilladas ni descoloridas
a menudo éstas terminan siendo alimento
para ganado pero un grupo de granjeros
afectados también por un aumento de los
aranceles les encontró un nuevo uso
están haciendo andrés harinas sin gluten
iniciaron vendiendo a pequeños clientes
y ahora los buscan en tiendas naturistas
y chefs de todo el país escuchemos
cuando llevamos las lentejas al cielo si
no alcanza en una cierta especificación
visual se desechan a pesar de que son
extremadamente ricas en proteínas y
fibra y no tienen absolutamente nada de
malo entonces comenzamos a probar la
harina en nuestros niños y ponerla en
sus comidas y usarla para espesar salsas
y ahora la he estado usando en muchos de
nuestros productos horneados burga page
tweets indicadores semanales daniela
bueno el street acumulado pérdidas leves
en una semana marcada por resultados
empresariales y rumores de que habrá
aumento de impuestos a las altas rentas
las bolsas europeas marcaron su primera
pérdida semanal en ocho semanas en medio
de un empeoramiento global de la
pandemia en américa latina hubo cambios
leves en la semana al alza para méxico y
a la baja para brasil y la cifra el día
49 mil 667 dólares a ese precio cayó el
bitcoin la cripta moneda más grande y
popular del mundo al cierre de una mala
semana para este tipo de inversión en
españa y en turquía se destaparon dos
grandes supuestas estafas como cryptome
2 andrés daniela como siempre muchas
gracias por traernos la información
económica de ustedes muchas gracias por
sintonizarnos continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]